ana
Yes 0 Then the
princess is completely lost. In the
mountains like this, true g I don't have to worry about the magic stones being taken first by other people
.
You can also find the magic stone you're looking for. Rator
ah ah ah
[music]
rar
ah ah ah
[music]
Let's calm down and sort out the situation.
I wonder if my magic stone was taken by a crow, and
the crow I mentioned earlier shouldn't have gone that far yet.
Furthermore, I'm sure there is a seat somewhere in this mountain.
The crow I brought is collecting this. I
don't have any more tea. I don't know. I've been
headed
to 300.
It's better not to rest, so it's better
to go down the mountain and re-plan.
Is the Nochahime so far?